there are 500 million people from 27
countries living in the European Union
we have the right to live work travel
and shop anywhere in Europe we make over
a billion cross-border trips every year
and 12 million of us live in another EU
country but sometimes we face barriers
to our rights and our freedom to move
across Europe the European Union is
working to make sure everyone benefits
from the same rights in everyday
situations for the 97 million working
women in Europe who earn around 17% less
than men and make up early 12% of
company boards the EU is pushing for
equal pay and equal access to
decision-making as a European citizen
your rights are protected at home abroad
and online